the Joe Rogan experience Raziel I mean
how badass of people from Brazil and
that's [ __ ] paradise - yeah but in
ruff-ruff paradise it's a little
different down to Brazil you know I
think a lot crime yeah I get them
Brazilians a lot of respect they they
you know some of them they really uh
they come about and nothing you know and
literally out of nothing you know and to
build that respect around a community
and stuff I give it to him I do as well
and you know you got to give it up to
them for creating Brazilian Jujitsu I
mean they they essentially revolutionize
jiu-jitsu yeah I mean the the the Gracie
family is the most important family in
the history of martial arts and what
they did with Brazil and Brazilian
jiu-jitsu and how Brazilian jiu-jitsu
evolved in that country you know just
they took to it like a duck to water man
yeah I wonder what it is about a Brazil
that that was like the one place to test
it you know I I think if they if that
count my ADA had gone anywhere else if
he had landed and talked to some other
dude somewhere I think they got lucky
they found a Leo Gracie and Carlos
Gracie and they found some dudes who
were just straight-up warriors and they
taught those guys and those guys were I
mean a Leo Gracie just really him and
Carlos just thought it through and then
we're willing to test it in real
competition against people much larger
than them the fact that Elio was a small
man he wasn't a large framed man is the
reason why Brazilian jiu-jitsu became so
effective because Elio had to fight off
of his back he had a tire out bigger
guys first they had to develop the the
concept of cooking your opponent you
know all that wasn't in Japanese
jiu-jitsu it wasn't in judo judo is a
beautiful elegant martial arts with
fantastic technique and powerful moves
but it wasn't Brazilian jiu-jitsu
Brazilian jiu-jitsu is largely a part of
this one dynamic incredible family if
you look at that family all the [ __ ]
champions hoist hor Ian Hickson yeah you
know I mean come on that high in crazy
and now Krone yeah I mean Jesus Christ
that what a [ __ ] family man hens
yeah yeah I'm high in I mean just just
Gracie after Gracie
Jannetty who you saw Gracie like oh no
killers just straight killers yeah I
mean the game has changed a little bit
since but don't forget Carlson Gracie -
the game has changed a little bit since
then but but it has been because it mi
sure it's it evolved in that area and
sprung out and of course you know
obviously there's you know Muay Thai
from Thailand Dutch kickboxing American
wrestling there's so many different
factors Russian wrestling so many
different factors that come into what we
now call mixed martial arts today but
man I just keep thinking that if it
wasn't for that one family who the [ __ ]
knows because the part of what made the
ultimate fighters so spectacular or the
Ultimate Fighting Championship brother
in the first two ones was hoisted being
this guy who's not this physically
terrifying guy like it was Mark Coleman
if Mark called me 265 muscles up his
neck straight up to the top of his head
his neck would just like come off of his
shoulders here he was huge if he won
you'd be like yeah that makes sense yeah
but when hoist one everybody was like
[ __ ] I gotta learn jujitsu yeah look
that guy choked I'd do that with his
legs yeah
[Applause]